you as concerned as some people are that
were eventually or we already are in a
direct war with Iran I mean let's face
it we are in a a proxy war with Iran we
are providing weapons uh to people who
are under assault uh by proxies of Iran
so guess what you've got you we're we're
basically at war with Iran and they know
it what they don't want is us to make
direct moves on Naval assets and when
you see the word in Naval assets that is
an Iranian warship with guys on it and
what they don't want is that thing to be
sunk and so that's what they're talking
about and the US um you know the foreign
policy under Reagan was you chip my
tooth I'm taking off your head that's
basically the way it worked and that's
how strength through peace is
accomplished here I think they've
realized that we have been trying to
stay on the sidelines and support our
friends and support our friends
indirectly we